we're almost there okay so the next stop
in mnsure is a grass security and
environment here at purplish we will be
talking about some work is done over the
summer on the security of lwe with
binary sequence with the Christine
butter so this will be a half an hour to
30 minutes and then right after that
we'll have the open problem massage on
right right away so thanks Erin for
coming from my talk I'm so be talking
about the concrete security of lwe a
small secret and this was done as a
summer internship project last summer
with Christine Lauda how Chernin young
system at Microsoft Research in Bremen
so just give some very basic
introduction about lattices so we'll
consider a set of the linearly
independent real vectors and a lattice
generated by this basis B as formed by
this vectors will be the set of integer
linear combinations of them and this is
an example of a two-dimensional lattice
and the shorter specter problems us to
find the shortest nonzero vector in the
lattice and you had you know the the
length of this shortest vector by lambda
1 so in general there are two types of
algorithms for solving SVG and so the
first type is exact algorithms for
solving them and they are generally two
different types of this which are
enumeration algorithms so basically you
enumerate all the lattice points within
some radius and track which is the
shortest vector and the other algorithm
is sieving and there are also another
class of algorithms for solving SCP
which are approximate algorithms so this
do not find the shortest vector exactly
but they finally up to some error and
these are generally lettuce reduction
algorithms and so the most famous
lattice reduction algorithm will be the
our algorithm and this is
very fast so it works in polynomial time
but it has an exponential I wrote the
dimension so it's not very useful in
practice but if you under run practical
active reduction attacks people
generally us wise cut the bkz algorithm
so this works by solving the exact SVP
on blocks of a fixed size which we
called a block length and there's a
baron of this bkz algorithm which is
caught because e 2.0 which currently has
the best performance in practice and
I'll be discussing more about this later
so the goal of this work is to
understand the concrete security levels
for homomorphic encryption so
homomorphic encryption is basically a
way to compute do computations on
encrypted data and it's based on lwe
with small secrets and in this world we
have run experiments on instances of
small dimensions to better understand
the behavior of bkz 2.0 and our goal is
also to compute heuristic estimates of
the Hermit vector which measures the
performance of the algorithm and to see
how they compare with experimental data
and to do this your study was called the
USB key attack on lwe using the bit easy
to point your algorithm and I'll explain
each of these terms in more detail so I
was first start by describing how bkz
works so so there's a parameter bkz
which is called the block size which we
generally do know as beta and so if you
have a basis of some lengthy we first
start with a block the first block of
size beta which is the first beta
vectors in the basis and we use an exact
enumeration algorithm to find the
shortest vector in this projector
lattice there's been by the vectors in
this block and then if this shutters
factor is not the first factor in the
block we put the brightest of the block
and run our reduction to get a new basis
or size beta and
we repeat on the next block which is the
the vectors we do to be beta plus 1 and
we continue doing this yeah so we call
the basis because II reduce if the first
vector of this block is the shortest in
the projector lattice and this variant
called because e 2.0 improves on this
basic bkz algorithm with some
optimizations such as extreme pruning so
one way to measure the quality of this
that this reduction is using what we
called a remnant vector so this is
defined as the quantity Delta here in
this formula so we have we have a
lattice basis B and we usually call b1
the shortest vector in the basis and the
volume of the lattice is the determinant
of this matrix B and Delta relays the
size of the shortest vector the volume
of the lattice and there are two
different ways to interpret this
definition of the Reutimann factor so
the first way is if we have this type of
a concrete lattice basis then we can
compute the Reutimann factor and a
second way to interpret this is the
effect of a lattice reduction algorithm
so given some so if we have an algorithm
which has a really affected Delta then
the claim is that given an arbitrary
basis the algorithm finds outputs a
reduced basis read of as the shortest
vector satisfies this Lange constraint
and so does this estimate which is also
given in the previous talk so this is
due to China in 2013 and so for big hazy
block size beta there's this asymptotic
formula for how for what how Delta
depends on beta so for large beta this
is you can think of this as around beta
to the 1 over 2 beta and 2 so to choose
this block size beta in practice the
idea is that if you under successive
alehrer cover the shortest vector we
need to twist beta so that this Delta
here satisfies that so the b1 the Lang
of the shuttle's vector output by the
algorithm just given by Delta to a D
times the volume of the lattice to 1
over D should be less than the second
shot effect on the lattice and if this
happens then you should butter recovered
a shot inspector if you ran because a
block size beta on this like this so now
go on to define the learning with iris
problem yeah so basically we fix a
dimension and of the lattice and a prime
model ask you you pick some matrix a
with entries sample uniformly at random
from zq and we have some error the
sample from a discrete Gaussian
distribution and in this particular
world will consider secrets the sample
from three different distributions so
the first distribution is the binary
distribution where the entries of the
secrets are in 0 or 1 and the second is
the ternary distribution where they are
0 minus 1 or 1 and the third
distribution is the Gaussian
distribution where the secrets have
entries sample from the same discrete
Gaussian distribution as the error and
given all these quantities you are
compute B which is a times s plus II
molecule and this
instance you'll be given the matrix a
and B the goal is to find the secret s
we are softest our W problem by relating
it to the unique shortest vector problem
so yeah so we define the first and
second minimum the lattice as follows so
lambda 1 will just be the length of the
shortest vector in the lattice and
lambda 2 is you can think of the ester
lying on a second shot as vector so you
consider are linearly independent
vectors V 1 and V 2 and take the minimum
this that you get and so the unique
shortest vector problem or the usvp
problem with some get gamma will be an
instance where lambda 2 is at this gamma
times lambda 1 and in what follows I
would describe this usvp attack on lwe
which works when the secret has a small
norm so the first step is to reduce our
instance of lwe
the instance of bounded distance
decoding of
BBD and in a second step you reduce this
VD D to a USDP problem and lastly the
softest usvp problem using lattice
reduction such as because e 2.0 which I
described before so I'll start with the
reduction from LW e to be DB so so first
you consider this lattice that's
generated by this matrix be zero so a is
defined by the iOW instance and q is the
modulus of the view and we'll construct
this instance of bundle distance
decoding which is to find the process
like this point to this target zero B
where B is equal to s plus C yeah and so
the solution to this will be given by so
if you get a solution to be D D then you
can write a of this form
this you can see that it's a small shift
from the target and given this solution
you'll be able to recover the original
sequence of the lwe problem so the next
step is to reduce this to the usvp
problem so given the BDD instance with
some target T we construct an instance
of the unique shortest vector problem by
constructing this lattice yeah and then
if you have a solution though the BDD
you can yeah you'll find that the
shortest vector in this lattice you'll
be given by this vector vicious and you
can recover the secret given this if you
solve this usvp problem you'll make a
further optimization so when the secret
and the errors are sampled from
different distributions we can optimize
it further by balancing the secret with
a constant Omega so that the norms of
the secret and the errors are the
similar and in this case you'll get a
new shortest vector which is given by
this formula and for the case of binary
sequence you choose Omega to be root 2
times Sigma where Sigma is the width of
the Gaussian distribution and for
ternary Secrets which was square root of
2 over 2 times Sigma and for the case of
Gaussian sequence Omega is just 1
and now I will discuss how we estimate
the parameters so so before we have this
like bigger we are embedding our inserts
of lwe into this bigger matrix but the
only exactly tell you how to choose M so
this is the first thing that we will
discuss so to do this your first have to
give some estimates of what lambda 1 and
lambda 2 are so since we chose our
letters in a specific way
we know exactly what the shortest vector
is and using that we can estimate lambda
1 in terms of the Hemingway of the
secret and the standard deviation of the
Gaussian distribution and you also
assume that lambda 2 is given by the
Gaussian you estate which is basically
the length of the shortest vector in a
random lattice of the same dimension so
the way we are choice the dimensions of
the lattice reduction is using two
famous estimation or literature sort of
assisted to estimate and a second Esther
to one success to me you should you
might already heard off in the previous
talk yeah so first our discussed uh to
estimate so the idea behind this
estimate is that you can mystically
recover the shortest vector in the
lattice if the gap between the between
lambda 2 and lambda 1 is big enough so
more precisely we can so if we write
gamma as the gap then V 1 gamma to be at
least delta T whether I start vector up
to some constant multiple and so
basically what we want to do here is to
optimize gamma and for specific instance
we plug in our parameters and to
maximize gamma we have to choose omegas
as this quantity and and then we'll get
this formula for the dimension of the
big Galactus that we are embedding the
LW problem into
and if we plug this parameters back into
this the first formula will get an
estimate of what Delta is in terms of
the other parameters of the problem and
your coded to it estimate for Delta
and next I'll talk about this 201 6
estimate which is from the new home key
exchange paper so I'll briefly describe
how this estimate works so basically you
assume that this the geometric series
assumption holds which is so the idea is
that when you run bkz after many tours
of the bkz algorithm you expect the
norms of the garnishment vectors to
follow a geometric series and and this
off the US VP problem using bkz you
assume that the after running the
Bokashi algorithm if at the last block
of size beta the projection of your
unique shortest vector to this last
block is shorter than what you expect at
that point given the geometric series
assumption then the SVP algorithm that
you call in that last block should be
able to recover this project that
shorter specter and using that you can
recover the rest of the shorter Spectre
yeah and well conclude the you'll get
this if you for me formulate this you'll
get this inequality for to relate lambda
1 with the norms of the gram-schmidt
vectors and if you plug in the
parameters in a specific problem then
you can and you manipulate it you'll get
that you get this estimate of the human
factor given this assumption to be
around to be given by this formula
so here I have a summary of how the
different estimates of the room in fact
that I discuss so first is the
definition that is just based on the
concrete lattice basis and the second is
this jeunesse to me which only depends
on beta and and you have this 200 s me
and 201 sex estimate that from the new
hope people and so in this world we also
try to compare these different estimates
on concrete experimental instances so
the Tauri estimate does is not dependent
on because he is the host or general
that is lattices whereas the other
estimates are more specific for BKG
so I'm now describe our experimental
setup so what we did was to generate
random
lwe instances and convert them to
instances of us BP by other procedure
that I described earlier and you'll
considered the dimensions of our FW
instances will be between 40 and 200 and
you consider Secrets there are sample
from binary ternary and gaussians
distributions and our Gaussian
distributions have this error with which
is 3.2 this sort of standard and we are
computers because that is dimension for
the usvp problem based on the 208 or 201
six estimates so we choose the lwe
numbers and perth based on this
estimates because using the estimates we
can solve compute what's the optimal
value of the dimension yeah yeah and
because of time and resource constraints
we only consider block sizes 30 35 40
and 45 and we do ten trials per set of
parameters and we use the big easy to
point your algorithm that's implemented
in FP RL to find a shuttle sector and in
our experiments we start with small
values of Q and we increase lock you to
determine the smallest value of lock you
way well because e 2.0 success in
recovering the secret and for these
values of lock you'll you'll get some
value of a home in factor and we split
them into successful vs. unsuccessful
instances of the attack and we plot them
so here's a sample platform binary
sequence in this plot we have so we are
plotting Delta against the dimension of
the lattice and so the green dots are
the successful instances of the USB P
attack and the rates outside are few
instances and the blue dots are computer
using an
stimate and the black line is trans
estimate which only depends on the block
size the model is coming from the
assumption that projected lattices so I
guess that's one of the takeaways from
this world which is that we can that
most of these estimates only hope for
large block sizes so they don't really
whole if we try to use them on smaller
small block sizes and dimensions yeah I
agree
yeah so so from this graph I guess it
was of the general trend that the values
of Delta for the successful instances
decrease whereas for the fill their
instances they increases and any follows
a similar trend as the estimates which
are appear to converge to us trans
estimate and this as the dimension
increases and so this is just a
representative plot for beta cos 30 but
you observe a similar behavior for the
other block sizes and this is the plot
for ternary sequence and and for
gaussian secrets
how meaningful yeah so I guess in this
case because we successfully find the
shortest factor that explains why the
Reutimann effect is much smaller than
then the estimates isn't a function of
the volume by its unusually short vector
yeah so I guess from the plants we have
these observations that I mentioned and
and more notably we observe that best
amazed at least for these dimensions and
block sizes which are not which are
probably not what this estimates are
designed for that in this cases the
estimates fail to predict the successful
sensors because like so if if we were to
predict that there will be this
successful instances we expect that this
values of Delta should at least be below
the values of Delta for the few
instances but in this case they are very
close to the few instances so they don't
seem to be able predict this success so
soft because II at these small
dimensions and block sizes so basically
you run the because you're going to see
if we can cover shot a specter so since
you chose the secret vector we know yeah
we know what secret is so we can
determine whether we recover the secret
exactly yeah and then if it does then we
call it a success instance and if it
doesn't require failure
yeah and we split the experiments based
on this success and failure
the secret was affecting the probability
of success it should but you you don't
seem to report the exact length of the
sample Darrow when you do when you
follow the Gaussian distribution some
some of the thing are going to be
smaller than expected and some are going
to be larger so maybe factor yeah I
guess we ran it for and this time Krauss
each but yeah I guess this you might
need more time then to run more
experiments so it's somewhere try on
average case of those so an extreme case
where where where's the secret you are
looking for shorter or longer to see how
it effects and then you only need to run
the latest reduction of you time but you
still get more relevant information yeah
that's a good situation
okay so here I have a plot of the
running times of the algorithm to find a
shot inspector and so you can see that
increases a lot with the block size and
due to our time limitations you're
unable to run it for hire block sizes
but ideally it would be nice to repeat
our experiments for higher dimensions
and block sizes and of course more
chouse so yeah for the last part at all
I'll discuss some some experiments we
did with the TVM stat lwe challenges so
so using this same experimental setup we
generate the instances of the of this
LWE challenges following the same
parameters on the website but with
different secret distributions so in the
original challenges they consider lwe
uniform sequence but we are anybody like
do this with our limited power so we
considered binary thunderian Gaussian
sequence and so the rest are just the
standard parameters in the actual
challenges so they consider Gaussian
distributions with varying standard
deviations and the dimensions of the
lattices are from 40 120 and you'll run
the usvp attack using which is e 2.0
with the same block size SS before so
this is a soft plot of of what we get so
in this plot
so you're plotting n against our father
which is the standard deviation of the
Gaussian distribution and the blue
squares up is greater that that's our
parameters there have been soft on the
actual LW challenges but for uniform
secrets yeah so the and the red squares
so the blue sky is also really yeah but
the red squares are those where we
generate the same the same instances by
binary sequence and we solve them using
eSATA and we successfully recovered a
secret vector
and for the yellow and orange squares
there's uni we cover them for some of
the trousers but not all and for the
green one sure anybody recover anything
and here's a soft time comparison so so
this is like the state of the art for
uniform secrets which is like a
challenge
so for N equals 50 and Al Fakher 0.02 so
the best algorithm known so far is the
sleeping algorithm which takes two
hundred two hours by V run the same
attack using binary sequence instead we
can successfully recover using only two
hours so we did something similar with
ternary secrets and yeah because a
similar plot but we found our success
rate and this takes yeah this takes
slightly longer so we get 2.5 hours for
the same parameter set and then we
repeat the Gaussian secrets we have a
much lower success rate so I guess the
main conclusions are that the success
rates for the binary and ternary secret
distributions are much higher when we
tried to break them then the Gaussian
distributions and one follow-up would be
to explore if this could be caused by a
difference in the l1 norm of the secrets
khasinau said that we redesigned the
instances so that they have the same l2
norm but differing our one nomes it will
be interesting to study this more
systematically and your so highlight is
that in practice is not such a great
idea to use binary or ternary secret
distributions because their security is
not so well understood for future well
it will also be interesting this to
extend this to uniform sequence we shall
use in the actual challenges
yeah and this is that the top and thank
you for attention
[Applause]
for the comparison between binary and
ternary and Yeltsin did you tried
plotting like a security level observed
in your taxes experiments versus the
sizes you would need for crypto systems
because then something which is of
interest for a lot of submissions to the
Miss contest distributions is you know
people are trying to get the cipher text
sizes down on the public key sizes down
yeah I think they'll be interesting to
study like you know what we are mostly
focusing on the hog meat factor so we
didn't really take the end will come
okay well thanks again
[Applause]